we didn't sign odell to trade him you
know i just i want to compete i want to
be legendary i just think that cats
ruined him my goal was always to be in
the hall of fame to win trophies to be
able to leave a legacy i mean this is
one of the biggest trades we've ever
seen in the history of the nfl it was
purely a football business decision john
dorsey's thanos right now
i'm very happy to have odell beckham as
the 17th pick in the 2019 draft nobody
else really matters i think this moment
is going to be more iconic than we all
realize the entire bar started chanting
no b.j the excitement is real gentlemen
i really think we're going to see the
fury unleashed
let the games
begin that was a great great segment
that they put together we used it
yesterday for the browns uh and odell
beckham jr closer analysis of that
situation but now odell beckham jr we
made the point yesterday he had only
been in cleveland one day right since
being traded to the browns for the first
day of the entire offseason program met
with the media said all the right things
and then left
back in cleveland chris mortensen vspn
reports that he will participate in
today's ota that's phase three organized
team activity it's basically football
practice but odell is back and and i
think that that's good he needs to
establish those relationships with his
teammates yeah no and you know again i
think it's also helpful that he's got
people there that he knows already so
jarvis landry can can let teammates know
what's going on or what odell beckham's
like his old college receiver all those
things are going to help yes you know
you want to get him there that's great
i'm so glad he is there because we don't
have to talk about this and go why is he
not there but i fully always expected
him to be at the mini camp and otas when
it comes to on-field football work you
know odell beckham jr for the most part
has always been there and been ready to
to to work and again you know how did we
first find out yesterday that odell
beckham jr was in cleveland well there
was an instagram story by antonio
callaway and we saw odell beckham jr in
the background so right away he was
there with the teammates once again um i
i said this to people last night when we
were at our little nbc gathering people
always ask me about odell beckham jr and
the giants come up of course because of
my father and everything else but uh
it's undefeated
as far as players i've ever talked to
that are around odell beckham jr he is
loved there is not a player on the team
in
new york that i could ever find and i
talk to like
all different positions safeties
receivers offensive linemen you mention
it they love odell beckham jr so he
might not be always perfect i get that
and there's things i wish he would have
done differently but at the end of the
day i think we always make a bigger deal
about him than we should what was the
disconnect though because one of the
reasons we make a big deal about him is
the giants were exasperated by him
landon collins said that last week what
was the problem with the front office
why didn't they like the guy if the
teammates love him and he's one of the
best receivers in football i think he's
a little too brash for them to to really
just for lack of a better phrase you
know i look at the giant situation in a
lot of ways too and a little bit like we
talked about with the jacksonville
jaguars where you know i think a lot of
people on the team and especially the
offensive side of the ball said man
we're all being held accountable but you
know there was 20 receivers open during
the game and the quarterback didn't
throw the ball and he still seems to get
to play and nobody talks about it so i
think that added to the the dysfunction
of everything all together you know all
around to where he's frustrated he's not
getting the ball he doesn't feel like
the weapons were being utilized and you
know he does seem like the type of
personality that's
not afraid to say things out loud
whether the coaches or the owners are in
the room and you know sometimes
certain organizations just can't handle
that they want these guys to be robots
yeah they it's amazing right they want
them to act like that
this is what we say behave a certain way
and they'll hurt themselves as an
organization to justify getting rid of
someone that makes them uncomfortable
because of the way the guy is right how
was it hurting the team yeah no i know i
i don't i don't think it was a
distraction that maybe the public tried
to make it out to be well we'll see what
kind of distraction or not he is for the
cleveland browns that's for another day
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports